voici les modèles
merci beaucoup
voilà je suis toujours deux cas locaux
sinon c'est qu'ils sont extraordinaires
non
tant qu'il est mignon et quand je lis
qu'un - il s'appelle il s'appelle terry
aïcha petit bain c'est normal d une
grande trompe pas
voilà ça c'est le tube des monnaies il
ya un prochain single qui sort au début
de l'été et à la rentrée un album
beaucoup beaucoup d'e-mails suite à nice
people
madame guy de saint mandé qui vous
demande comment ça va ça va très bien
bonnes vacances
ouais nager polyvore au tennis avec des
casseroles dans la piscine comme ça et
on s'est fait masser c'était très bien
ça allait alors kévin guez de sarcelles
est ce que vous voulez boire quelque
chose oui mais non de l'eau publique de
l'eau de l'eau de l'eau s'il vous plaît
un autre mail de béziers est ce que vous
aimez le sexe il aime c'est toi qui
répond aussi bon façon à faire après
laquelle elle est sèchement ce que tout
le monde aime les sectes oui et non
les enfants adorent les fake
spontanément bien sûr bien sûr alors
bernard de la bourboule
ils me demandent le sexe de qui en
particulier
kevin
ce moment c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup de
travail comme tout le monde le fait mais
c'est pour ça que j'espère faire un tout
petit éléphant cie je devrais choisir je
choisirais son sexe tu es tu choisirais
tu sais que j'ai tiré à l'accord des
petites y est bien
alors au mail de marseille avez vous
déjà eu des relations homosexuelles
entre vous entre nous je ne connaîtrais
ritaline envers chacune
on se cale et l'on se fait des bisons
bien sûr bien sûr quand vous êtes en
tournée comme ça le soir dans les
chambres d'hôtel non non non non la même
ligne que jamais si bien sûr ça nous
arrive tous dormir ensemble mais c'est
très très copines on aime bien se faire
des bisous
alors encore au maire de marseille
est ce que c'est important les gros
seins dans votre métier de chanteuse
non non non on an'a pas derrière nous
oui et alors ps laquelle elle est plus
bonnichon il faut savoir que ils
s'entraînent ils sont très différents
dans sa mission bien tous les tous les
six
je dis bien alors voilà vous rendez
compte 2000 on a reçu on a reçu 2007
s'en mêle
quand les gens su que vous veniez dans
l'émission incroyable tout ça pour
quelques jours passés dans la villa
d'arthur peur à nice tout ça pour toi
pts j'ai très bien comme ça initiateur
semaine dans la villa d'arthur y ait des
mails dans tous les sens combien vous
avez reçu d'argent pour cette séance
d'humiliation et de mex beaucoup
d'argent et jean pascal jean pascal le
garçon adorable élaboré par est gentil
un email ce problème ou de retirer ses
laquelle la bloque il est valable
y'a vraiment des gens qui inquiète pour
l heure c est quand même enfin bien donc
est-ce qu'à l'intérieur de la villa
d'arthur c'était aussi chiant que à la
télé quand on le regarde et nous je
pense que c'est moi je pense que ce qui
montre à la télé n'a rien à voir avec ce
qui se passe dedans tout simplement de
danser c'est autre chose et demi il va
s'arrêter lui non c'est pas tant
non j'ai préféré ne pas laisser les pnc
pour reporter sans frontières cc pour la
montée les scolaires et les journalistes
ils sont emprisonnés à l'étranger c'est
vrai j'aimerais qu'il ait un vraiment je
le dis pour les enchères comme ça je
veux dire c'est un peu la honte histoire
de nice people non non non non mon
expérience formidable vraiment ça a été
très sympa et puis c'est pas des
attardés montaut faut le dire ils sont
pas bêtes ils sont très cultivé ils sont
très intelligents des choses biens sont
pas filmés alors sur vous demander
d'aller vous enfermer pendant une
semaine avec des singes aux autres
singes avec des sages au zoo de
vincennes
parce que dirigée dans une cage
n'importe quel animal gym et moi j'adore
encore un même avion vous cacher je
pense que c'est dedans l'expérience et
doit être évitée
tu verras tu découvriras thierry un soir
donc toi irène était d'accord pour les
singes aux autres vincennes kim vous
seriez d'accord moi je suis blonde il ya
certaines questions que je comprends pas
bien va rester dans le domaine de la
télévision va regarder un extrait de
cette émission on y revoit en cas oui
mais oui en cas de remplacement noir
qu'il ne fait plus partie des modèles ce
laurent manito 17 ans dans le coma
bien alors les mots days donc qu'est oui
bonsoir vous vous appelez en cas sur les
cétacés
hank aaron entier et vous livre toutes
les trois vierge et la c3
en cas vous dit tu fais l'amour
- tu en as besoin très bien en cas
pourquoi vous n'avez pas de mec
bon je prends deux mecs parce que j'ai
pas trouvé la mecque de ma vie on côtoie
la georges fenech soler
voilà c'était en quarts en cas la
roumaine anca 80
61 90 et maintenant irène parce que je
vous considère un petit peu peur mais la
cheffe des models
vous allez me dire pourquoi en cas est
parti
ont des histoires personnelles mais
c'est face à ces personnes et pour quels
bénéfices explique est peut-être mais on
peut décider de suivre d'autres chemins
quel chemin
je fais man aventure peut-être je sais
pas j'ai pas de l'amour de l'amour
garantir pourquoi aucun parti ou sf
météo
wet wet hockey en caoutchouc et la
maison chanel pourquoi elle et pas des
moindres le paradis
le
je ne sais pas
seconde
nous avons mieux nous avons mieux nous
avons kim alors kim vous remplacer en
cas et franchement je dois dire que vous
êtes encore plus jolie que en cas enfin
du moins à mon goût alors kim 80 59 85
vous quotidien de la moitié des
portables à chaque fois
on dit qu'on appelle avec ça alors vous
êtes vietnamienne vous avez 25 ans vous
êtes une amie diren et de québec et
depuis depuis une longue date voilà
alors vos cheveux vos yeux blonds sont
étonnants évidemment chez une
vietnamienne mais c'est le résultat d'un
clonage vous avez un clonage avec un
sens tant brebis comme si c'est la
cousine de devenir non mais non c'est un
clonage c'est quoi ma grand mère qui est
la mienne dans la guerre d'indochine a
invoqué une histoire d'amour avec un
militaire français
et ça ce team général je demande
toujours à quoi ça a servi la guerre
d'indochine voilà pour les groupes cette
manie si oui on dirait un truc est
retouché au photoshop
alors on regrette que je veux dire non
qu'il y avait dans la vie un peu seul
qui vous êtes célibataire
pas pour longtemps j'ai toujours dit un
truc moi toujours toujours dit le jour
je rencontre à une vietnamienne blonde
aux yeux bleus
je l'épouserais c'était pas ça le
dernier mot la france était bien c'est
incroyable non
voilà c'est fait sur famille sans bras
avec les et tirait dessus et ils ont
vraiment une qu elle a vraiment grandi
dans une culture asiatique le vietnamien
suis tout le fait de la main sur
vraiment c'est vraiment comment dit on
mange en parlant en vietnamien a comme
mourir at high comme en irak
heiko mirass commander des crevettes
alors pour savoir si kim mérite de
remplacer en cas on va comparer vos
réponses aux avec celle d'en cas dans
l'interdît auparavant kim est ce que par
amour vous seriez prête à vous déguiser
en elton john ah oui comme encas
incroyable qui mus que par amour vous
seriez prête à vous droguez non comme
encas est-ce que par aman vous auriez
prête à prendre 17 kg qu'est ce qu'elle
a répondu en cas marche pas comme ça
comme qui me l'a dit
alors est ce que vous seriez pas ta
prohm 17 kg non quand mon cas est ce que
par aman vous seriez prête attention tu
as peut-être aller vivre à limoges
pourquoi dommage parce que les voir tu
vas voir tu racontes facile donc la
réponse est dans mon cas oui mon cas
c'est incroyable c'est un clown vraiment
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
cacher quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer par
amour une femme oui comme encas
d'ailleurs je crois que là on assiste
vraiment à un sans faute je pense que
les a pas de est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à embrasser cent fois ses
chaussettes sales non sens fiscal
comment karanka répondu le mec qui me
demande ça il dégage tout de suite oui
c'est le cas c'est son côté elena
ceausescu est très est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à fréquenter les clubs
échangistes
comment cas c'est incroyable c'est
vraiment on a alors est-ce que par amour
vous soyez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle a beaucoup mieux ok
bien bien bien elle est mieux d'accord
pour être esclaves sexuelles c'est bien
sur mac dans la chanson c'est important
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête
qui m'a accepté quelques infidélités
nantes où chaque nation est sensible bah
moi tu voulais mais vit sa porte si ça
peut rendre un réseau de le coupe oui
pourquoi pas on sent la différence entre
la vietnamienne et la roumaine
c'est dire qu'en cas avait répondu
jamais et vous vous êtes prêtre c'est
bien vous êtes plus maligne c'est bien
j'ai tout compris vous allez garder
longtemps tirs hier dix ans
les adore
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu